before we start the main meeting this
evening I'm going to read out the
emergency evacuation announcement should
we be required to evacuate the building
would you please leave the building via
the nearest available exit to the
chamber our assembly point will be in
the public carpark at the side of the
Civic suite please do not delay your
evacuation to include to collect any
belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff please note that this
meeting will be audio recorded thank you
five members please be upstanding to
receive the chairman the Chairman step
chaplain and the managing director
chairman teller council is the season of
Advent is almost upon us and in this
season within the Christian Church we
are reminded of the silent years or the
apparent silent years of God between the
last prophet of the Old Testament and
the miracle birth of Jesus as told in
the Gospels of the New Testament yet in
that period of silence there was still
hope in that timeframe in this fast
approaching season of Advent there are
still the issues that the silent years
had of poverty homelessness despair and
anxiety there are still those who wield
earthly authority and power the question
remains where is hope the answer of
course is there is still how do we see
that challenge well
Pope Francis wrote this we must restore
hope to young people help the old be
open to the Future spread love be poor
among the poor we need to include the
excluded and preached peace in the book
of Hebrews chapter 6 we read these words
we have this hope as an anchor for the
Soul firm and secure the Christian
message in this season of fast
approaching Advent is that there is hope
for a ruined Humanity hope of pardon
hope of peace with God hope for glory
because at the Father's will Jesus
became poor from this place
from this council chamber the people of
the community are desperately seeking
hope and responsibility lies within this
chamber to bring hope in a despairing
community let us pray
by the God we are reminded that when you
sent your son Jesus into this world
there was hope and that hope remains in
this society
although fast changing and becoming ever
increasingly secular you are still
present and as council meets this
evening
may the presence of Almighty God be
sensed here and all the discussions that
are taken forward bringing hope to the
community that each counselor serves and
we ask these things in the name of Jesus
Christ amen
thank you very much good evening
everybody
um before we start the formal part of
our meeting I'm asking for there any
tributes for the late councillor Chris
black councillor Stanley
thank you very much for many years we
have I'll start with you sorry for many
of us it will take a long time to come
to terms with a sudden knows that their
friend and colleague Chris councillor
Chris black that's passed away I'm sure
that goes for all of those present
tonight and for many who served with
this authority over the last quarter of
a century our hearts go out to his wife
Elena and grown-up son Alex who he loved
and was loved by them for many years
together to try and do Chris justice
within five short minutes or indeed five
hours would be impossible you will have
your own memories and I'm sure it will
be those recollections that which we
hold it most dear Chris was most
definitely part of the furniture
at the council they've definitely set
the standard as a hard-working and loyal
cancer to which we all as fire light and
respected by members from all sides over
a 30-year period he remained
enthusiastic to the age
despite his local popularity each
election was as nerve-racking as the
first for Chris he never took his
residents support for granted Nora
Sherman T will be reelected by you
always returned with the big majority
Chris was frequently out and about in a
walk where many of his residents still
refer to him as young Chris which was
quite the compliment at fifty years plus
he was unstinting in his work throughout
the year residents know that if they had
a problem Chris could we like be relied
upon to assist speaking to members they
all described Chris in the same way a
good debater excellent on planning are
very amicable to approach Anna lovely
man perhaps Chris lammle who worked with
Chris for such a long time sums up the
kind of counselor Chris was he says
Chris was highly intelligent and his
dedication to Residence he's well
recorded he was an expert on planning
law and would always help a new
counselor when asked he was a brilliant
debater
he was not a controlling leader of the
group and was generous he allowed me to
represent the liberal view on the
working party considering recycling and
renovation of the Reilly windmill it was
also a very pleased with the work Joan
did as chairman of the review committee
Chris loved the Rochford district and
blogged about issues and items of
interest on his online focus website
which was often politically neutral
welcoming Hall who had the area's
interest at heart most of all though
Chris was passionate about stopping them
the overdevelopment of Rainey and to
protect the charm and character of the
town where he had lived his entire life
Chris will be remembered for a long time
but so many people but by so many people
for his dedication to rhenium rostro
district he will be greatly missed the
donations raised at Chris's funeral in
support of the Samaritans was nearly six
hundred pounds and thank you to everyone
who attended and donated to this charity
that Chris was so passionate about we
would like to ask the leader of the
council with the support of the members
if a permanent memorial to recognize the
hard work and length of the service that
Chris Pratt gave if this will be
possible thank you
can still hook life
that's that's on this evening and both
teen Hren and I heard the sad news of
Chris blacks passing whilst we were on
holiday being in such a wonderful
environment the shock of this
information was quite overwhelming they
took a while to sink in I began to
reflect on the man I had only known for
a few years and on some of these
achievements the obvious one being his
long service to his community and the
fact that he'd been a member of this
council since 1984 to put this into
perspective I reflected on what I was
doing at this time I was studying at
Civic like Chris had done a few years
before preparing to take my a-levels
one of which was politics and world
affairs I was contemplating a career in
the RAS with the ambition of being a
fast jet pilot although this was never
realized I had just had my heart broken
by my first girlfriend the reality is is
that all my adult working life Chris had
been made working for his community and
getting himself re-elected whatever the
political climate the only way for this
man to achieve this feat is if he was
admired and respected by the residents
he represented fast forward to may 2014
and I'm elected to the council 30 years
after Chris part of a new breed and
quite green I'm certain he was not quite
sure what to make of me and my
colleagues like many of you but it was
not long before the gentlemen that he
was was offering advice and being
helpful I soon recognized that this was
someone I could respect and work with
we came from different political
traditions and covered by different
banners but I do not recall having a
political argument with Chris
there was discussion and sometimes a
different point of view but always
conducted in a friendly and often jokey
manner tina has told me of an occasion
during a meeting when Christie expressed
to her you have a good point and have
argued it well but I still do not agree
with you she could not have been
offended by his remark the last time I
saw Chris it was late September and a
nice warm sunny afternoon and we had
both just arrived for a training session
as I got out of the car he looked me up
and down and with a broad grin said I
never thought I'd see the day a member
attending a training course in shorts
and I'd never expect it of a UK person
I'm sure he was having a teague but I
laughed along with him and this will be
my last in memory of Chris thank you
Thank You councillor Mason Thank You
chairman thank you very much for
agreeing to include attributes to the
rape counselor Chris black in this
meeting today I'm grateful for that and
how sad I am to look across here and not
see my friend I I looked across the
chris many times during debates for
inspiration and support and I always got
it and that's something that I miss
already
like everyone I've talked to about the
news of Chris is very sudden passing it
was it was then and it still II it's a
terribly sad shock my thoughts remain
with his with his family Lena and and
Sasha I first met Chris in a social
capacity through mutual friends it was
actually through his best man so I've
known Chris for over thirty years
well it was 33 to be precise and he was
impressive then even as a newly elected
member I was certainly well impressed
I kept bumping Turing into him in
community context and I have no doubt at
all that he inspired me to represent my
own community so any new member as other
members of audience couldn't said he was
very welcoming and helpful in sharing
his experience and nor more so when I
became a great leader myself he
supported me he helped me and he made me
think about the role I had we had many
discussions certainly we didn't have any
discussions of disagreement it was
always one where Chris was supportive
and generous we never put the phone down
on each other thinking anything but well
that was a very great exchange I'm glad
we had it I know where we are I know
where we stand and I knew when we came
into the chamber that he would still
support me Chris has led an exemplary
public life and residents of rally and
of course our district have much to
thank him for over so many brilliant
years I have to come up with
had some anecdotal experience of
Chrissy's influence I was having coffee
with friends in Cyprus and a lady joined
us and she asked what part of Essex I
came from I told her that it was from
Rockford and the first thing she said
was do you know Chris black I think that
says it all
he's influenced had no boundary thank
you thank you counselor counselor hi was
next sorry thank you madam chairman or
it would be brief although there's other
people who said Chris deserves far
longer than I could we have time tonight
to discuss or talk about I first came
into contact with Chris in about 2008
2009 purely as a result of him contact
him he and encouraging me to be cover
counsellor for the Green Party which he
said was surprising for me because I've
not really been involved in politics
like that before where you've got
members from different parties
encouraging other parties to stand as a
counselor and we had some coffees and
some discussions and in it continued
from there I've never failed to find
Chris anything other than a gentleman
and a lovely man I think gentleman
describes him very well and this being
said many times will be said again and
again as councillor mr. Mason says I I
still expect him to be sitting over
there and he's not there and it's very
sad it's a great loss to this council
it's a great loss to air residents an
example of his dedication was I I do
remember one planning meeting when he
was on holiday and he turned up for the
planning meeting and I was talking to
him he said no on our got a flight back
early just so I could come to the
planning meeting tonight
and that's his dedication
councillor camo
Thank You chairman
I think it's a great shock to all of us
when we heard about Chris black I know
that Shawn phoned me and he said oh you
said I think he said are you sitting
down or he prepared for a shock
and he gave me one because the last
person I thought that would suffer the
fate that Chris did would be Chris black
because I can't remember when he lost
mr. meeting frankly because he was that
sort of man having said that of course a
relationship if you can call it
relationship as such it goes back over
seventeen and a half years when I was
first elected as a young counselor
sitting just over there somewhere
and I can remember the planning meetings
where he was actually sitting in front
of me down with these seats and we
actually exchanged views on things
during planning meetings it's not too
much because we didn't want to I didn't
think annoyed the Chairman too much but
we actually supported each other because
there was no no politics to speak of in
planning meetings in those days and and
that was Chris and there will be
suggestions coming forward not just
about that but about other things too
inside the chamber yes of course Chris
and I could still visualize him sitting
there and it seems strange without him
because he's almost part of the
furniture
you know we challenge if you like and
that's fine you know you need challenges
as a administration and he always gave
that challenge and he thought it through
and he was very clever and very cunning
in the way that he did that it like
nobody else he could always find an
angle into something and that was Chris
but having said that I can remember
Chris when we were sitting here in
meetings particularly the planning
meetings and of course you've got to
remember that Chris was a very busy man
he worked hard in his in his ward in his
constituency and for his own people but
he worked hard in his in his work as
well and he worked long hours he had
lots of phone calls you know which ships
coming in etc and in those times
I can remember when the phone rang which
of course you're not really supposed to
do in meetings but you had to do it
because yet if you had a [ __ ] coming in
yet to get there and I'll remember us
laughing because he popped them sea
shanties on his phone and that would
seem to be appropriate really for what
he was doing at the time but outside of
the chamber
Chris and I had a good relationship I
can remember some of the interviews we
had with the various check the various
achieving executives that we had before
sitting down and chatting and I could
call him a friend and there's not many
people outside of my own party if you
like that I can do that with but I
genuinely could do it the grease and if
he he actually had a principal he'd
stick to that principal he wouldn't just
change it for party matters and things
like that and I think this part this
this chamber will be less of a place
without him I think you can't replace
Chris for what you had with all respect
to my colleagues here and I think that's
what's gonna be missing from this
chamber so I do miss him as pirate
Memorial is concerned I think something
to be considered I'm sure we can look
into that and I'm sure my fellows would
contribute to that as well because then
sorry speak that we had for Chris thank
you Jim
councillor mrs. Mason
I agree with everything that might poke
the previous speakers and I can't match
their eloquence I just want to say that
the late councilor Chris black was
gently funny kind and helpful and the
fast experience has left a huge vacuum
in his chamber i sat next to him for
some time he was always helpful
I also echo canceller Stanley has said
in because the couple has kindly agreed
that some sort of permanent memorial
whose remarkable service and I'm
grateful that something will be arranged
and implemented I think that's fitting
for such a lengthy service so I think
the council isn't even look Chris Thank
You counselors for that at their last
meeting we had our silence for Chris and
I think everybody was in shock so very
few people nobody spoke in tribute to
him because of that shock I knew him as
a very kind knowledgeable man and I know
he will be very greatly missed by this
council and by the residents in Rockford
so thank you for your kind words
so we will now start the meeting and
item one is apologies for absence and I
have four received in the office
councillor Lumley councillor Eliot Mason
counts on the mountain and councillor
Western other any more
no item to to receive declarations of
interest are there any item three is the
new local plan issues and options
document draft consultation document
draft sustainability appraisal and
consultation and engagement summary 2017
call counts despairing thank you
chairman on the 17th of November with a
planning policy subcommittee met to
discuss the new local plan issues and
options document job consultation
documents we discussed individually all
eight evidential documents including the
Tschida the strategic housing and
employment land availability assessment
due to duty to cooperate with other
councils the [ __ ] and travellers
accommodation assessment infrastructure
delivery topic paper 2017 all of these
documents meeting the current
legislation requirements which have been
put in place by successive governments
but of course these quick change of
central government move the goal posts
officers hard work has ensured that we
am Rochford are ahead of the game in
respect of our plans whereas some other
local councils have already been
contacted by the government officials
chasing for information regarding their
plans during our meeting members asked
numerous questions or sought
clarification on various items to which
officers responded fully and ultimately
the net result of these discussions
contributed to items three and four on
this aged evenings agenda with the
subcommittee's recommend
Asians no doubt members who were not
permitted to ask questions on these
documents at the subcommittee meeting
will want to raise issues but I'm
confident that either officers counselor
Walden myself will be able to answer
them alternatively give prompt responses
after further investigations while
numerous issues were raised and answered
or clarified as the case may have been
it is essential that we do our utmost to
get the public to engage with these
issues as it will affect every every one
presently in the district and those who
will become residents in the future we
appreciate that this is a huge document
what we hope the residents who have
concerns in respect of a particular
issue will concentrate on that and
submit their views during the
consultation period we are fully aware
that our evidence in support of our
plans for the future of our district
must be robust and be able to stand up
to instant intensive scrutiny from both
within this chamber and outside as will
the evidence that we have received from
third parties we will also ensure that
the evidence presented by other councils
must be able to stand up to the same
scrutiny to which they will subject us I
am sure we will hear the usual views
that we cannot cope with more housing
the lack of infrastructure etc and that
some people will try to score political
points in relation to this long term
plan for our district and while it's
very pleasing to hear that County have
stated infrastructure first sadly to
date their track record does not support
this I'm in my views this is not just a
conservative group issue but it is
incumbent on everyone both inside and
outside this chamber to work together
for the best possible results for our
residents and the successful future
planned development of our district
thank you chairman
councillor Ward
[Music]
Thank You chairman first and foremost I
would like to thank our officers for the
very hard work they put in to producing
this document it's quite huge and it has
a lot of detail in there our concept was
to make this new local plan like no
others that have been done before what
we have learnt from experience is that
residents with their local knowledge
together with their input and the desire
to get involved will be at the heart of
this local plan when we started the
local plan making process we consulted
with both the parishes and Town Council
together with local residents who
attended the various sessions up and
down the district enabling them to voice
the issues of concern to them most were
unaware of how much influence they could
have from vitally needed improvements to
their locality our concern has always
been to get residents involved at the
earliest stages of plan making to enrich
the process or else we may miss out on
the possibility of identifying all the
necessary infrastructure and amenities
needed within their local communities it
has also been previously mentioned that
ideally it should be in infrastructure
first we're a development requires it
previous governments labor coalition and
Conservative have set targets for
housing delivery which councils have had
to comply with often at odds with the
local community it has also become
obvious to us that without the
protection of a statutory local plan and
what it gives us we would be open season
for developers to build anywhere for the
present how do we deal with the
immediate impact presented of a possible
identified housing need of 7500 houses
over the next 20 years
firstly this is an unconstrained need
secondly that need is inclusive of
already allocated land with planning
permissions in place awaiting
development and thirdly the local plan
we are embarking on will catalog the
issues identified in the independent
evidence-based reports regarding the
current constraints this body of
evidence covers a large variety of
issues amongst which both the
environmental and infrastructural
constraints figures highly it is
important to repeat emphasize and
understand that the 7500 figure is an
unconstrained need which as yet takes no
consideration of the current
environmental and infrastructural
restrictions prevalent in the district
that could possibly demonstrate a need
to reduce the level of identified
housing need good plan making will
identify the most appropriate locations
and ensure we build in the right places
we still need houses for our local needs
what you can be assured of is that we
are here to uphold that democratic
process of asking listening explaining
debating and then deciding the best way
forward that benefits our local
residents long-term and this will be
available to the press as well thank you
very much madam chin councillor Mason
Thank You chairman I'm not going to do
any political point-scoring this evening
either except that I will say that in
terms of a risk of open season I can't
say that I've noticed that in Castle
Point Basildon or indeed Brentwood so
maybe that was something which was said
in 2006 7 which hasn't been
one out nevertheless this council is
embarking on its second local plan
whilst our districts haven't even
managed to deliver one chairman this
public consultation is important it's
very important in shaping the future of
our district and I hope the council will
amongst other forms of communication
will approve a leaflet to be delivered
to every home so everyone has the
opportunity and awareness of the public
consultation that we're going to agree
to tonight it's also absolutely
important that every ward councillor
I'll repeat that every ward councillor
has a long hard look at the evidence and
challenge with facts
if 7500 new dwellings are possible and
whether it could deliver an acceptable
balance of life in all aspects for our
residents it is clearly not it's not
acceptable but as other members have
student said we must prove it before a
planning inspector at a public
examination in due course personally I
don't think that the real
infrastructural needs not just to be of
junctions can be materially improved
because of both physical and monetary
constraints I remember standing in 2008
and getting agreement from the then
portfolio holder councillor Hudson
should I say former council Adson and
saying that we needed 2 billion pounds
to do something really decent to improve
Jeff get alone be the highway
infrastructure in our district quite
frankly having listened to the
Chancellor at the budget it ain't going
to happen
it ain't going to happen
yes I do come from Essex air council
itself needs to become the champion old
it's a big picture because I can't see
anybody else willing to take on this
responsibility but absolutely nothing
from any MPs on the subject I've heard
nothing actually from any county
councillors tonight either or before and
as Council sparing safe infrastructure
first yeah that's what it should be
infrastructure first the number is going
to be proven unacceptable
but what number it will be and where
houses that we need will be built I
don't know councillor Hoya died in 2008
proposed that we only had the number of
houses we needed to meet our local needs
we were laughed at councillor Hawaii I
was called openly in the chamber and on
the online focus which Chris black
managed so well that I was a member of
the passport from Pimlico Party
well I'm proud of that still and that's
where we need to be we need to be not
with this 7,500 we need to be for the
number we need locally and can be
completely supported by the
infrastructure we have and not some wish
lists that we'd like to see it isn't
going to happen we have to work with
what we've got and tinkering at the ages
is not going to be sufficient to
generate a huge number of houses that is
why we need the views of stakeholders
residents and any organisation which
will help provide the evidence I've just
got one question Jalen which I kind of
missed that planning policy subcommittee
we're not going to deliver this until
2021
but the plan is for 2017 237 so when we
deliver this we're going to be
delivering a shortfall I wonder if we
mayn't 2021 to 2040 one Chairman I would
like to hear from the offices as to how
we deal with that particular issue thank
you Jim
so yeah
Thank You chairman just in response and
and this is my experience from doing
plans in the past you don't actually
have to have the start date starting
when the plan is adopted a lot of plans
start pre prior to that date starting
and that's the same for our planned if
you think example of when we had
Regional Planning and when the regional
plan was adopted and when that start
date for the housing that that was prior
to the start of many other plans
starting and that was the case for
Rochford South End and other Southeast
ixora T's so it doesn't have to be the
case that you start the plan and adopt
it as the start date of when you adopt
that plan
if it helps I got to come back on that
because that didn't answer the whole of
my question forgive me but I'm gonna say
okay so we start with a shortfall okay
we are short because we only have been
delivering 250 at best a year plus
windfalls which don't count anyway so if
we start off short short of the whatever
figure is is the only fully constrained
need how do we catch up Thank You Jen
the start date is just the start of the
plan period so it's not a shortfall from
when you adopt it you've already started
delivering from that period prior to
that adoption date because houses have
already come forward before that date so
there's a plan period that maybe 15 20
years and you have a shortfall if you're
not delivering to that target yes so
even if you adopt in in 21 if you have a
start date before that that's when your
plan period actually begins and that's
the same that's not unusual for a plan
Thank You chairman I'd like to thank the
officers and those members on the
planning policy committee and those that
supported them for producing this
document I mean 251 pages chairman is
not you know there's not a light
document not every member can know every
word that's in there but I think they'll
read the bits that they want to read
and certainly the bits that relate to
their own wards and I think that's quite
the correct thing to do to actually look
at your own area but obviously as a
district councillor you've got to look
to the whole dish as to how you consider
how things can be consistent delivered
in a sustainable and proper way yes
we've got a long time table leading up
to this and I think part four of this
agenda is actually back at that time
table and how we take things forward but
having said that I think you know this
is the beginning of the beginning if you
like as far as our local plan is
concerned but I think those who sit in
this chamber who were at the last
planning process that we went through
will remember the pain the
inward-looking and and indeed the legal
challenges that we had relating to that
plan but having said that having a plan
and I think it's already been mentioned
has actually stopped development and if
I look over to my fellow councils in
around us there have been challenges
there have been legal constraints
there's one at the moment I think this
is legal technicality relating to a
development over in Castle Point so I
don't accept that I think we would be
open to the firing line for developers
on things like coops farm because if you
think about Coombs farm the only reason
we actually defended that was because we
had a plan if you look at hook or West
chairman and the Christmas tree farm
originally there was an application for
300 orders well we managed to reduce
that to the proper 175 that we had
because we had a plan if we hadn't had
that plan we would be very difficult to
resist what came along so the planning
process actually does work for our area
and it does work in accordance with what
we are wanting for the districts and
what the Republican wanting but I think
it's incredibly important that those
that can contribute do contribute I
think we should put
time for something so that we make sure
that every household that wants to
contribute to this and to make sure that
where they do contribute they're doing
it on the lines that they actually know
something about their area and make sure
that they can do something I don't think
you're going to get too many people that
want to have development near them but
of course we do gain things from
development and you know those things
have come forward and I think people
forget that too but I'm looking forward
to the debate on this if there is gonna
be debate but I I think it's the right
way forward that we're gonna go forward
and as I say yes I think it's been said
we're very much ahead of the game in
Rockford and we should be proud of that
camp counselor mr. hi thank you madam
chairman I said I think a lot of its be
simply Catholic come on counselor
mr. Mason all ready I wasn't quite here
at this stage at the first plane I was a
resident who was not aware of what was
going on with this process and I would
like to say to councilor sparing that I
think the process so far it's far better
than that time and I think he
understands the issues residents have
around what they consider the
consultation name he did ask I did ask
him at the subcommittee if I could ask
questions he said no because of time
constraints all our say is that I think
that the subcommittee was very good and
I think all my questions were answered
there's a few which weren't but they've
come out either afterwards with with
emails to offices or or will come out
through the consultation process I
believe there are I could I can only
echo what Kasim makes mr. Mason has said
which is this is very important for
residents to respond to and for
councillors to respond to and to
understand how they respond with
evidence of why the numbers are
constrained on the seven and a half
thousand why transport may be an issue
not just because it is theirs if you
read the inspectors report from the
first local plan you'll see that yes he
was happy that this
evidence was being supplied in in figure
format but there was no evidence
produced from that way it would affect
the numbers why they should change so
although people provided figures they
didn't provide them as evidence and
demonstrate how they would in technical
terms affect those numbers and this is
where it's important we do that
I think the leaflets are very important
I think a leaflet through the door on
its own isn't I think it has to be a
well-written leaflet or just like
confirmation of if that's going to be
written by Natalie or by the air
communications team I think she's done a
very good job with this report is much
more readable in the first one I think
counsel Mason
mr. Mason said that at the subcommittee
actually and I would just like to know
the answer today thank you yeah I just
like to confirm that it it's a joint
it's a joint leaflet so it would be
between the policy officers in
consultation with their communications
team and for everything that we're doing
we are doing that in consultation with
our communications team to make sure
that is understandable and it contains
the right information as well cancel
hook way thank you madam chairman there
was a matter that was brought up at the
planning training session which involved
a little bit of a discussion and it was
who's asked of the offices that that
whether they could attempt to make as
much to capture potential windfall
within the scope of this document and
how the process was gonna was going to
happen he was interesting to go back and
analyze some of the the figures from the
previous ten years to see that on
average 38 homes per per annum were were
built as windfall and if we look at the
figures of potential numbers that's over
10 percent of what we might be looking
at in the future so I think it's
important that the document is as
comprehensive as possible and and that
the counselors can help that the air
office its offices to identify potential
windfall sites so that nothing is left
and no stone is left unturned and that
we accompany can provide as much
evidence that we've done a comprehensive
job with with this report and the future
process as well
another another thing that he's
constantly mentioned is it's about local
need and homes for local people the
reality is is that we do not have an
overall control on this because most of
the properties are end up being on the
market and therefore they can end up
being sold outside of this district to
people coming in from wherever we've
already got evidence of some local
authorities purchasing properties within
the district to accommodate their needs
and they're homeless so I think we all
need to be aware of that situation and I
think the we should be trying to make
sure that whatever properties that come
forward are those which are homes that
our local residents can afford and not
just properties which which fill the
bank balances of large developers thank
you councillor Ward
thank you madam chairman just as an
interesting response to counsel the hook
way in regards to local Hong's we
actually had a conversation with the
Hall Road where they were selling their
houses and apparently it would seem that
with the exception of one property which
had been sold to people who lived in
Hutten all the rest were apparently
being bought by local people at that
moment and that that was very
interesting as far as we were concerned
that that was the take-up in regard to
council a licensed suggestion where we
have the leaflets I think this was well
discussed at at the meeting we had and I
would fully support the fact of those
leaflets and in fact one of the things
that had been discussed to my you know
to keep the cost down with regard to
delivering I know that some of the wards
especially let say my own Lodge and I
know Trinity they were prepared to
actually go out and deliver those
leaflets but I believe that marriage
director Sean Scranton has actually
identified a costing which would come
within the budget and if this council
are minded to go down that road of being
happy for that budget to be allocated I
would support that
thank you I caps nieces Mason was next
thank you madam chairman I'd like to go
back to the question of numbers with the
officer because although he's obviously
attempted to explain it I'm afraid that
it hasn't appeared clear to me I think
we understand that with an emerging plan
that the date doesn't matter it goes to
2037 wherever it whatever it's adopted
in that which is quite clear
but the numbers aren't clear at the
moment we under our existing plan we're
providing hopefully optimistically 250
homes a year therefore at the moment
from 2017 1892 whenever this new plan is
adopting we don't know what the numbers
will be under that new plan now just for
argument's sake for round numbers if
that's 500 the emerging plan
we won't know what the numbers are going
to be so we will be providing 250 houses
a year so for argument's sake if the
plan was finally adopted in 2020 which
is three years down the line we're all
ready and if it was 500
we're 750 short now that's how I see it
if I'm wrong please clarify because I
can't see that if the emerging plan is
that adopted at the latest a and we are
then therefore delivering at the lower
rate of our existing plan that there
won't be a thoughtful that we've been
have an impact on with other years
please clarify thank you yes only only
to clarify that yes there will be a
shortfall for that period beforehand yes
if that helps you
yep council mr. Mason thank you Kevin
slightly out of order but no not out of
order just out of order that was nearly
a mistake wasn't it councillor Ward
stood and supported the recommendation
from the plain Policy Committee we're
both well he was a member as a
substitute well I'm a member of it
yes I'd said before I think leaving
every house will be you know truly
excellent thing to do we do have a
budget that budget was acquired around a
year ago maybe a bit more than a year
actually in July 16 I think it was and
15,000 pounds and you know from what I
know of the costs of leaflets and
delivery
that budget will do it and I hope the
council through the portfolio holder use
the budget and it's a portfolio holders
decision at that level there's a further
aspect about the leaflets obviously
members are concerned that they are fit
for the purpose and they do give the
message that members want to get across
the residence and that is that this is
very important it is about our future
all that you know appropriately all
those appropriate constructions around
it and I wondered whether the planning
policy subcommittee should come back
together very rapidly when the drafts
available and take a look at it before
it's commissioned just to make sure that
that engagement hits in exactly the way
members would like to see it I would
read that is something that I hope that
the administration can take and take on
take forward and see happen thank each
other
just for clarification in relation to
the budget I'm actually checked after
the planning policy subcommittee meeting
and there is no budget there for members
this evening we'll need to agree to put
that budget forward in order to deal
with the the leafleting issue thank you
Jim
Thank You chairman well I think two
items have come to to notice straight
away as chairman our sub subcommittee I
have no problem if they feel it would be
appropriate to have a quick meeting to
look at the the leaflet and sign off on
that or make any amendments as as need
beep I think we need to have you know
he's gonna be an atom when and very
quickly done with regard to the budget I
don't quite understand because that
conversation was had at that time and I
would recommend then that if if that is
the case that there is an amendment to
the recommendation that this budget does
be is found and that we support it I
have no problem that it's all chairman
thank you
[Music]
hmm to say I think the original
allocation that was mentioned within the
report was 15,000 are we still looking
at that figure yes chairman
so we've got motion and you've second in
it so it's that agreed right if there's
nobody else to speak on this we'll go
through the recommendations one by one
so number one is that the draft issues
and options document and accompanying
interim sustainability appraisal as
attached to Appendix A and B
respectively be published for formal
public consultation for up to 12 weeks
is that agreed number two that the
sustainability appraisal scoping report
as attached as Appendix C to be noted as
evidence and published on the council's
website is that a grade number three
that the activities set out in the
consultation and engagement summary is
attached at appendix D be noted and
published on the council's website is
that agreed and number four is that
leaflets circulation to all properties
in the district be included as part of
the public consultation and that is not
using the existing leaflet leaflets
budget but insuring that that budget is
is found from existing and that the
leaflet before it's delivered is
approved by the subcommittee is that a
grade
thank you so we now go to item 4 which
is the new local plan issues and options
document local development scheme 2017
to 21 councillor sparing Thank You
chairman I think most of the criteria
that we we've discussed already and has
been stated both by myself councillor
Ward and the timetable that has
subsequently been submitted he's all
pretty legible and therefore as chairman
subject to members wishing to ask any
further questions I would make the
recommendation be accepted by this
council thank you
[Music]
is that agreed
but there is an issue the basics County
with regards to the risk
this would be
where he suggested we should be someone
who actually is
what I'd like to see is that where there
is infrastructure they are ready we are
not using infrastructure size
it seems completely done now I
understand that this is just the first
we need to actually approach from a
point of view of logic as well
if areas
as far as the SC is concerned yeah we
don't see any issue with adding an extra
risk related to infrastructure delivery
by bio six Cancer Council as our
statutory partner in this
so yeah that's fine Thank You chairman
I'm glad to answer if you like it and
I'm sure that my fellow council
councillors who are in this chamber
would also agree I mean one of the last
resolutions that were apart from the
resolution relating to infrastructure
first that we put through was a relation
resolution relating to if you like the
movement of traffic and the main
thoroughfares that we go go through and
I know that the local members here that
spoke at that meeting spoke about the
one to seven and how it is important
strategically for Rochford to make sure
that we can actually get a flow of
traffic going out from Rockford so you
know there is that support from County
Council now there is that push from
other county councillors to actually do
that but obviously it depends on the
individual developments that we're
looking for within the future now if you
look through the current local plan
there's a list of actually the
infrastructure requirements to meet the
development of those specific areas in
there and by and large we've been met
that as far as the local plan is
concerned and what I'd like to see
within the new local plan is for that to
continue to make sure that every
development that's going to come forward
in a sustainable way does actually
include the infrastructure requirements
for that and that's a part of if you
like including that development going
forward
because without it it's going to be
difficult to actually deliver that
develop development in a sustainable way
so I'm agreeing with my colleague in the
fact that you know you need to have that
infrastructure due to be put in to make
sure we get sustainable development
going forward but having said that of
course some of these things cost money
not all the 106 money is or whatever
monies come food we'll do that
but we're seeking government grants
through the County Council's to make
sure that some of those come forward so
there is ongoing work I'm also working
with other local councils within the
South of Essex to make sure that we
actually work on a joint plan going
forward and we all know what each
other's doing because there are
synergies between us because people it
was interesting to look at that and see
that there's actually more commuters
going to South in there all to London
which was a surprise to me and you know
there's quite a few that go the
childhood those are done etc so I think
that's the sort of information that we
need to prove our case to say that we
need this infrastructure it's also
interesting in Rockford because we don't
have many of the industries that other
areas do such as baz lurman which i
think is how accounts for something like
22 percent of the gross domestic product
of essex and of course people will go to
those jobs and i think we know the last
figures a few years ago i saw the
figures i think we had 14,000 net out
commuters every day we also have people
going through our district to draw the
not go through the one to seven at
Southend
it's used to go through it but that's
that's that life as we have it
improvements to the 127 are even more
important because of that so going
forward chairman I think that's very
important but all of this going forward
and what's been mentioned should be part
of that consultation coming forward so
be under no illusion chairman that's the
important thing if there are issues like
that that's where the consultation comes
in and that's where it should go thank
you Jim
Thank You Jay but what concur with my
fellow County member and also agree with
the member bocalee behind me in my role
as deputy portfolio holder of economic
development at County there other
members there are getting mighty sick of
me keep banging on about the a 1 to 7 if
anybody who's met Ron Howard and he
mentions cam he had every possible
opportunity including when he met Prince
Charles the other day I'm using his
tactics believe you me that the what I
refer to as the a 1 to 7 economic
corridor right the way from here from
South in right the way through to the
m25 he's a very very important and key
issue throughout the whole of the
southeast Essex and believe you me every
single opportunity I get to bang on
about it I do think Jeff counseling is
too high thank you
okay I just wanted to raise a couple of
quiz in the back of what counselor cuts
board said I think the the issues to
I'll be brief the two of the issues we
have with Essex County Council are that
they do everything piecemeal although
all the infrastructure is considered on
a application or by site by site basis
not as an overall big picture might want
to call it that's that that's simple
I'll keep it leaves out there on a point
about by and large all that the
infrastructure improvements were
delivered our local plan which were
mentioned in the local plane on the
whole bridge ser 6i and B it was
mentioned specifically in the plan and
it was also mentioned specifically by
the inspector that any building there
should include the improvements
including the raising the bait of all
tree line to a high above sea level
those were not done so just as a point
is although we you may think they are
there are some the important parts which
were not done
counselor mr. Eisen Thank You chairman I
I thought we were all popping off so
have a nightcap but clearly not so I'll
try and be brief - it's good to hear
that the a12 seven is a focus but the
a12 seven is not everything in terms of
infrastructure in this course rate and
tackling infrastructural improvements
development by development doesn't take
into account as councilor hoist aid but
I repeat it in the big picture because
you know these these developments pass
traffic on one to another yet alone one
to another on the roads
other than the being 101 three and not
just talking about the side roads but
also the side roads needs to get on to
the next roads and although I'm not
terribly acquainted with the problems in
rainy people tell me about London roads
and they told me about the problems with
London Road in its connection to the a
130 and and other roads within Raley and
I can also tell you because the be 101
three is the most important Road in my
area the central part of the district
that also is something that needs to be
looked at because and be given
investment if we're going to be able to
support an increase in the number of
houses that we're currently delivering
on this plan that we have in place and
as I said earlier I I want to see
evidence
I wanna see evidence that there is the
money the will and the activity from
both government and County and the
District Council that to improve all the
instruction not just focus on the a one
two seven but all the infrastructure in
our district which improves things for
the lives of everyone that lives here in
comes here and if we if we don't do that
then sadly we can't support anything
like this number at all and as I said
earlier you'll have to fit the number of
houses to the infrastructure we've got
picture is important but I'm talking
about the picture just below that so if
you've got your big screen you've got
your next screen and the next screen is
the important one for me thank you
thank you madam chairman
I'm glad that the the issue of
infrastructure have been brought up and
debated in here and discussed the focus
of attention has been on roads very
important to a lot of our residents
I don't want members to not forget that
the infrastructure is not just purely
about roads it's also about other public
services to relation to schools and have
medical and health services as well we
must make sure that we provide evidence
to back up needs for for support for
these areas as it's a main issue for
many of my local residents about how
they defined that the current situation
let alone future situations with regard
to health and schools is not sufficient
for them presently thank you
councillor Ward thank you chairman for
let me come back I think you know in
answer to councillor Hook ways question
it's so so important to get involvement
with residents as we've said it is the
residents we want the residents to be
involved we need the local knowledge
that they can bring we went out to
canoed and we got the views from there
we went out to great Wakering we went to
all the parishes initially to talk to
them we need to enlarge that we need
more residents putting their input their
local knowledge into what we need as the
basic infrastructure the basic amenities
that will come from development so it's
a case of where development will need to
come we need to ensure that we get the
right 106 agreements in place that the
local residents want and need and I
think that's the important important
thing thank you
Thank You counselors we've got a
proposer and seconder for the recommend
date all right I've taken yeah thank you
madam chairman I'd like to point out
that from the planning the subcommittee
to before the other day when we was
there and councillor Wald actually came
up with with the diagnosis of we
continue to build and sooner or later
we're going to come to a grinding hole
if we don't get this infrastructure and
that's exactly what he said we will come
to a grinding halt if we don't get the
infrastructure and all that and I
remember you saying that and I think mr.
Mason said that yes you did yes you did
and I think he's quite right what you
said on on that on that principle and
I'd like to leave it like there thank
you thank you sorry I apologize I did
not see your hand up right so we we do
have a propose and a seconder for the
recommendation that is in in item four
would the proposal and second to be
happy for something about infrastructure
to be put into this the revised local
development scheme regarding the
infrastructure
we have any objection to putting that in
there to be noted that it is a risk yeah
I think so
so that's the recommendation then is
that agreed counselors thank you
and I now close the meeting at 8:40 p.m.